In this segment, we derive
and discuss the weak
law of large numbers.
It is a rather simple result,
but plays a central role
within probability theory.
The setting is as follows.
We start with some probability
distribution that has a
certain mean and variance, which
we assume to be finite.
We then draw independent random
variables out of this
distribution so that these
Xi's are independent and
identically distributed,
i.i.d.
for short.
What's going on here is that
we're carrying out a long
experiment during which
all of these random
variables are drawn.
Once we have drawn all of these
random variables, we can
calculate the average of the
values that have been
obtained, and this gives us
the so-called sample mean.
Notice that the sample mean is
a random variable because it
is a function of random
variables.
It should be distinguished from
the true mean, mu, which
is the expected value of the
Xi's, which is a number.
It is not random.
And mu is some kind of average
over all the possible outcomes
of the random variable Xi.
The sample mean is the simplest
and most natural way
for trying to estimate the true
mean, and the weak law of
large numbers will provide some
support to this notion.
Let us now look at the
properties of the sample mean.
Let us calculate its
expectation.
By the way, this object here
involves two different kinds
of averaging.
The sample mean averages over
the values observed during one
long experiment, whereas the
expectation averages over all
possible outcomes of
this experiment.
The expectation is some kind of
theoretical average because
we do not get to observe all the
possible outcomes of this
experiment, but the sample
mean is something that we
actually calculate on the basis
of our observations.
In any case, the expected value
of the sample mean, by
linearity, it is the expected
value of the numerator divided
by the denominator.
Using linearity once more, the
expected value of the sum is
the sum of the expected values,
and since each one of
those expected values is equal
to mu, we obtain n times mu
divided by n, which
leaves us with mu.
So the theoretical average,
the expected value of the
sample mean, is equal
to the true mean.
Let us now calculate the
variance of the sample mean.
The variance of a random
variable divided by a number
is the variance of that random
variable divided by the square
of that number.
Now, since the Xi's are
independent, the variance is
the sum of the variances.
And therefore, we obtain
n times the variance
of each one of them.
And after we simplify, this
leaves us with sigma
squared over n.
We're now in a position
to apply the Chebyshev
inequality.
The Chebyshev inequality tells
us that the distance of a
random variable from its mean,
being larger than a certain
number, has a probability that's
bounded above by the
variance of the random variable
of interest divided
by the square of the number
that we have here.
We have already calculated the
variance, and so this quantity
is sigma squared over n
times epsilon squared.
And now, if we consider epsilon
as a fixed number and
let n go to infinity, then what
we obtain is a limiting
value of 0.
So the probability of falling
far from the mean diminishes
to zero as we draw more
and more samples.
That's exactly what the weak law
of large numbers tells us.
If we fix any particular
epsilon, which is a positive
constant, the probability that
the sample mean falls away
from the true mean by more than
epsilon, that probability
becomes smaller and smaller and
converges to 0 as n goes
to infinity.
Let us now interpret the weak
law of large numbers.
As I already hinted, we have to
think in terms of one long
experiment, and during that
experiment, we draw several
independent random variables
drawn from the same
distribution.
One way of thinking about those
random variables is that
each one of them is equal to the
mean, the true mean, plus
some measurement noise, which
is a term that has zero
expected value.
And all of these noises
are independent.
So we have a collection of noisy
measurements, and then
we take those measurements and
form the average of them.
What the weak law of large
numbers tells us is that the
sample mean is unlikely to be
far off from the true mean.
And by far off, we mean at least
epsilon distance away.
So the sample mean is, in some
ways, a good way of estimating
the true mean.
If n is large enough, then we
have high confidence that the
sample mean gives us a value
that's close to the true mean.
As a special case let us
consider a probabilistic model
in which we repeat independently
many times the
same experiment.
There's a certain event
A associated with that
experiment that has a certain
probability, and each time
that we carry out the
experiment, we use an
indicator variable to indicate
whether the outcome was inside
the event or outside
the event.
So Xi is 1 if A occurs,
and it is 0 otherwise.
The expected value of the Xi's,
the true mean in this
case, is equal to
the number p.
In this particular example, the
sample mean just counts
how many times the event
A occurred out of the n
experiments that we carried
out, so it's the frequency
with which the event
A has occurred.
And we call it the empirical
frequency of event A. What the
weak law of large numbers tells
us is that the empirical
frequency will be close to the
probability of that event.
In this sense, it reinforces
or justifies the
interpretation of probabilities
as frequencies.